in a soup kitchen in Gaza volunteers
prepare food for struggling families
breaking their fast
in our seven years of charity work
people's needs and poverty have
increased due to The Siege on Gaza and
many people don't have food at home the
idea of the soup kitchen is to offer
prepared meals to people to alleviate
their difficult situation
every day during the fasting month of
Ramadan Bethel moktas charity Kitchen in
Rafa offers meals to as many as 170
families living in poor conditions
the World Bank says the power curating
Gaza is more than 50 percent
many people depend on Charities to
access food especially during this month
after Ramadan the soup kitchen will
continue to operate twice a week
every day I come and get food because we
cannot afford to cook at home we take
the food from here and break our fast
with it the situation is bad honestly we
can't buy anything or cook we should
receive money from the Ministry of
Social Affairs but so far it hasn't come
through
people say the increase in food prices
and the worsening humanitarian situation
caused by the decade-long Israeli and
Egyptian blockade has left them
struggling to make ends meet
but during this month of giving
Community Kitchens prove much needed
Comfort to those most in need
Al Jazeera